[موسيقى
] عالم الصوت الذي تم إنشاؤه بواسطة
العديد من الموسيقيين قوي جدًا لدرجة أنه إذا
شعرت بالقشعريرة فقد
تعرضنا لصفعات على وجهك ولكمات في
معدتك ، فهذا أمر شديد القوة وقوي للغاية ،
ولا يمكنني حقًا
ترجمته إلى كلمات  عليك فقط أن
تراها ، اسمي فابيو فونيني
وأنا مؤسس موسيقى الروك 1000 ، أكبر
فرقة روك على الأرض ، روك 1000 هي
فرقة مكونة من آلاف
وآلاف الموسيقيين القادمين من جميع أنحاء
العالم ، ننظم أحداثًا ضخمة حيث ينظم
المزيد  أكثر من ألف موسيقي يؤدون
كبار تينيسي لدينا 400 جيتار 250
عازف الطبول 300 قاعدة 350 مغني لدينا
موسيقيون من 30
دولة مختلفة في العالم من كوريا الجنوبية
من الولايات المتحدة من كندا من
البرازيل روسيا إيران التحدي اللوجستي
كبير جدًا مئات و
المئات من الأشخاص
يبنون مسرحًا بحجم ملعب كرة قدم لدينا
مئات الميكروفونات على بعد أميال وأميال
من الأسلاك والكابلات ، إنه لأمر مجنون على جميع
الموسيقيين  انفصلوا عن المنزل
وبمجرد وصولهم إلى هنا ، سيكون لديهم
ثلاثة أيام من التدريبات أيام مكثفة للغاية
[موسيقى]
حيث التقوا ببعضهم البعض وبدأوا
اللعب والاندماج معًا وبناء
سحر الرسالة الرئيسية وراء Rockin
1000 هي روح العمل الجماعي
فكرة أن الأشخاص الذين يلعبون دور
رجلهم الضخم أو يغنون تحت الدش
عندما يكونون جميعًا معًا يمكنهم
حقًا إحداث فرق وهي
رسالة تتجاوز الموسيقى كثيرًا
أعتقد أننا لا نحدث فرقًا في
التوجه الجنسي والتوجهات السياسية
والتوجهات الدينية الغنية  أو
المحترفين الفقراء أو المبتدئين ، فنحن ندرج
الجميع معًا بسبب
موسيقى الروك أند رول
[الموسيقى]